hello rejects gravy over here whoa yeah
okay
oh yeah this is Lisa Mallory I am Lisa a
talented lady wonderful beautiful woman
with a lot of skills and a variety of
humor
a variety a variety of humor this one
we're gonna watch them our friends top
five unknowns five scary truths behind
supernatural movies ready for this I
don't know the way you said it I just I
don't know you're right here we're gonna
talk about each one of these that it
makes me want to be prepared so yes hey
you answer your question do why am i
sweating so much because you're GERD
this is scary scary you're not sweating
at all sweating is not attractive
quality
not a Nike ad what's going down with the
amino hora it could be found at the App
Store coffee free we currently use it
ourselves
and we saw people's comments on it
wonder law really us well it is the app
is kind of like a social media style app
dedicated to horror on it we can share
content with each other based around
horror movies and TV shows but also our
content such as urban legends and
stories along with this yeah I want to
save the video one of the group oh
that's what you don't see that gruesome
face by skipping and it just made things
were complicated naive Vicki jelly on
his movies were not scary enough it was
frightening to find out that they were
based on true events
number 5 The Nightmare on Elm Street
this iconic Wes Craven movie follows a
group of teens the teens begin to have
bizarre nightmares which seem to have an
effect in the physical realm the person
haunting their dreams is a man by the
name of Freddy Krueger is an edge child
killer who was burned alive by a mob of
angry parents well he is now back to
haunt the kids in their dreams his
victims tried to stay awake to avoid
meeting him but they fail every time the
bizarre thing about this movie is that
Wes Craven was actually in
valued by real events where's Ivan
revealed then an article he read
inspired him the article was about a
family that survived the killing fields
in Cambodia the killing fields were a
number of locations in Cambodia where
collectively more than a million people
were killed it was a genocide that took
place under the Chimera gene in the
1970s the article had said that the
little boy in the family kept having
terrifying vivid nightmares that would
keep him up at night he told his family
he believed that whatever was chasing
him in his dreams would eventually catch
him and kill him due to the fear the boy
stayed up for days without sleep once he
finally fell asleep
his parents have thought the madness was
over this was until they heard him
screaming they rushed into him but he
had died the article stated that it died
during a nightmare oh my number4
what wow what wow as sad as that is I'm
gonna turn that fan on okay you have one
concern right now oh my god oh I'm glad
you needed to turn the fan on cuz I
needed a second to really consume that
whoa way to justify what I'm doing mmm
we're a team here for my awesome on
camping presence you know as we're
filming this we don't know if Trump is
president yet oh my
and you're going Ben that was a real
scary thing yeah you know you want to
talk about a nightmare coming to reality
now from California if you look at how
many people voted for Trump in
California not many
we're not Trump supporters a lot of us
out here we're very much a little
concern right now I have time this video
is up it could be Hillary or it could be
Trump but Trump's winning right now as
we speak
yeah that's a real nightmare on Herald
Street yeah I'm gonna wake up screaming
do you think that was real how he like
said something was chasing him and you
think that thing really killed him like
a demon they'll be pretty freaky huh
it'd be hot yeah no that's hard answer
that question because I'm not here to
call someone a liar but my god
just slide what happened he was making
that [ __ ] up he's got to scare when he
was dreams no that's our look I'm sorry
you're not here to make anyone feel like
they're lying but oh my god hey I could
believe it he imagined that where they
demon haunts you in your dream I'm gonna
have you just can't yeah I'm gonna help
that's good you'll attract one now I'm
not gonna sleep cuz I don't wanna isn't
that sad I think we can all relate to
this in some aspect when you don't want
to sleep because you stop it cuz you
don't want to dream because it's that
bad cuz you're afraid of what you might
dream yes yeah because dreams can be
vivid I've woken up and I'm like that
happened I know that happened and then I
have to like think about my day my night
before and be like no there's no way
that was a dream is no way that happened
but it gets real like that sometimes
maybe that was his situation I don't
know you know what I'm not gonna make a
joke I'm sorry I'll take that in and
respect it I'm sorry what did I say
you totally what do you mean what did
you what did I do no I'm saying I feel
like that for like wanting to make a
joke right now okay alrighty well can we
relate to that though I can totally
relate to that there are times where
I'll you know like the one time I slept
with a man okay I was having horrible
dream that like Trump supporters were
you know they were there matching at
Donald Trump elected this is my
nightmare
hmm when I had sex taking I'm taking
this in and I'm here for some work I
woke up what's that I didn't wake up
I thought Schroth I woke up and I
thought I saw Trump that you were
sleeping with and I and I killed this
guy I punched him to beat him to death
but it ended up not being Trump and now
Ben Harrison's body is out there
floating in the LA River
good mass let's go to number four or
five number four film off man prophesies
this one may be hard to believe release
into solitude the film follows a
journalist called John who is played by
Richard Gere while driving he and his
wife see a black flying figure and
swerved to avoid it they crashed the car
and his wife dies in hospital after this
John finds drawings of the figure in
which his wife Drew previous to the
crash after this he finds himself
traveling through Point Pleasant West
Virginia well there he goes searching
for a mysterious winged creature that
many people have reported the
descriptions match two drawings his wife
Don believe it or not this movie was
actually based on real occurrences that
happened during the late 1960s between
November 15th 1966 - the slender 15th
1967 residents of Point Pleasant started
reporting sightings of a mysterious
creature on November 12th 1966 five men
who were digging a grave at the cemetery
claimed to see a man-like figure fly out
from a tree and over their heads over
the next few days
many sightings were reported each report
described the same winged man type of
creature sightings continued for almost
a year this was in total December 15th
1967 on this day a bridge known as the
Silver Bridge collapsed oh the bridge
connected Point Pleasant and Gallipolis
Ohio it had collapsed showing rush-hour
and resulted in a death of 46 people
after this no more sightings of the
Mothman were reported this led to the
residents believing that the Mothman had
something to do with the collapse number
3 well woah a lot of people were
reporting seeing some type of like
supernatural creature yes that's [ __ ]
crazy crazy one time I saw Donald Trump
flying lasers really what this video is
out of his eyes shooting down at America
this was a dream I also had that was
more than nightmare right oh it's just
weird a lot of what they described just
reminded me a lot of what I imagined
with my Trump dream they're gonna have a
video about you wouldn't Trump was you
know like when you
all his true dark powers and you're
still having nightmares about I'm still
having nightmares this is a belief your
God don't go to bed I kid I tell God I
am not joking
I've seen Trump fly I must believe and I
must believe I have conviction because
dreams can't be that vivid you must have
this all about Trump wields that power
doesn't you know yeah it's like Superman
could be evil or he be good do you
believe in uh uh were you gonna say nope
hey no yeah man did not like that was
Lisa tell me what you said
merci Mon genuinely don't use it so that
was interesting all right I was gonna
wait for it to see what you were gonna
say well what I was gonna say is a
question to you me yeah do you believe
that there are supernatural beings out
there like that
how interesting gonna be if I hit dragon
anniversary again I'm not saying no
because I don't believe people when they
say that however it sounds like when I
say no I don't believe I was like well I
shall be okay I see what I just said
that what about what about was always
reports them help in my lifetime this is
why I here let me let me go back and in
my lifetime has that ever happened and
have I seen reports no I haven't I've
never had anyone come to me and
genuinely be like Lisa I saw the space
this is what it looked like
yes and if a near and dear friend came
to me and said and said that or foreign
acquaintance I don't know why they have
to be so near and dear if someone came
to me and said that I wouldn't be like
you are absolutely on something wild you
need to go get yourself no I would take
it in as a friend and I okay so to
answer your question let me totally
answered differently I guess I would I'm
just asking you think it's possible yes
okay I changed my answer to yes cuz of
what I just said what do you mean I just
want you to I want to see if you think
it's possible yeah yeah we're doing the
right thing we have a good conversation
do you think it's possible because has
it happened no but do I think it could
yeah and have I freaked myself out
before yes I have I have freaked myself
out before has it been anything no could
it have been probably and you what about
you
was it yeah I totally believe that could
happen we're on the same page if I saw
like some freaky creature flying around
in the sky
I'd be like [ __ ] you it man I talked
I knew bamboos with vampire fangs
existed with wings okay are you being
real right now
no I'm just saying if that happened I
would I wouldn't doubt it as something
would yeah cuz if we used to have crazy
creatures back then when dinosaurs
existed there was like this super easy
to go to the Kaaba super super rock
which was like the 84 foot wrap I'm sure
there's some crazy kind of monkeys back
that I'm just saying that like a lot of
these kind of creatures I'm on I'm on
the journey with you I get what you mean
but they've been like supernatural
creatures Oh like some type of demon I
know and I'm still on board with that
you know what really we're just confused
no no let's just move on no we're good
dramas gonna be forever anything's in
2005 it follows a 19 year old girl by
the name of Emily Rose after she enrolls
in university strange occurrences begin
in her dorm items start to move on their
own she begins to see demons oh that's
the episodes get worse
she becomes unable to eat and is
hospitalized oh yes then diagnosed with
epilepsy
however the medication prescribed her
has no effect
once she sent back home the symptoms
become oh my that is her friends believe
she made it impressed by a demon then
form Emily's family the kids in contact
with a priest who performs an exorcism
surely after this Emily dies due to
self-inflicted wounds mom Euler after
this the priest is sent to court as he
was accused with negligent homicide
this movie was actually based off the
terrifying story of Annalise Michelle
Annalise was a German woman who had an
exorcism performed on her in 1975 the
priests believed she was possessed by
demons when she turned 16 she had a
seizure and was diagnosed with f
let's see she was also treated for
depression at a psychiatric hospital at
the age of 20 she became much worse she
started to despise various religious
objects and she also started to hear
voices and felt suicidal her family
believed she was possessed by demons
reached out to a Catholic priests they
asked the priest if he could perform an
exorcism that he rejected shortly after
he got permission from a bishop and he
and his second priests performed several
exorcisms on Annalise for a course of 10
months
67 exorcisms were performed they would
usually be performed two times a week
and at last for hours there is an
alleged recording from one of the
sessions wow this is real in theory how
on the first of July 1976 Annalise died
in her home she died from dehydration
and malnutrition this was because she
refused to eat during her last few
exorcisms off the word spread about her
death her parents and the priests were
charged with negligent homicide number
two
haha Oh God whoa I think I stirred out a
section with the wall around my mind is
blown so in truck I'm just doing well
all charm jokes aside we fail to perform
a proper exorcism on Trump and now he's
dominating I was gonna say something
like he's scared to your cat yeah the
black cat got scared got scared I can't
blame that's really scary
you know I grew up Catholic you know I
was a welder Jesus you know they would
talk about how exorcisms are very real
in Catholic school yeah and yeah cuz I
went to one too I get it but then
hearing it here I'm like it sounds like
she had some type of schizophrenia yeah
mental breakdown else involved I might
have jumped
little too quick something else was
involved this was back in the day they
didn't know this Saturn but they still
go on exorcisms happened still like it's
crazy I mean maybe they're real see
that's the thing that's the thing
in theory we don't know it would be real
I might not call myself a Catholic no
more but I still go
someone's possessed by a demon I could
potentially buy that yes that voice
recording though does terrify that was
absolutely your freaky it's terrifying
it's his voice mail sounds like God that
would oh that was funny
wait here it was funny I appreciate that
thank you cuz now I'm imagining it
yeah no it'd just be fun the power of a
joke is not there gets your mind getting
your demons out she'll be back late okay
I'm done yeah you are funny little
butchering okay let's go so yeah I mean
that's you have you had a thank you I'm
joking
have you had an exorcism before uh no
have you um I would have liked to have
had a net you know what I think case you
had some demons but didn't know I felt
like we all have our demons I think what
if you don't know if you do or not so
should we all get one just in case I
think we should I mean before we go to
the doctor and waste a lot of money
getting your checkup you know get a
priest to do it for free it's like a flu
shot just in case we show or something
you should get your demons out yet
demons out we know we're talking about
we do we voted Hillary over to Ditka
this film was released in 2009 it's
about a family who moved to Connecticut
because of their ill son needs special
treatment and the hospital is located in
Connecticut you always looks a little
sappy food that's what the immune system
and needed special treatment for it this
resulted in the family driving back and
forth from the hospital one day when
they were driving back they noticed a
house that had a for rent sign which was
close to the hospital after viewing the
house they decided to move in this is
when it gets creepy the family realized
that the house used to be a funeral home
after this
creaking Park prospectivity begins and
the sick son starts to have visions of
spirits later on they find out that the
previous owners had performed seances
and would practice necromancy at the
home the spirits in the home become
extremely violent some forms of
possession occur this leads to the
family selling the house
the scary thing about this movie was
that was based on true events it was
based on reports from the snedecker
family they actually had a son called
Philip Snedeker who had cancer of the
immune system and due to this they moved
to Connecticut also the house was
actually a funeral klux here are some
eerie reports from the family according
to Carmen Snedeker who was the woman of
the house she claims her while she was
mopping the floors one day the water had
changed and looked like blood she said
that she was terrified and started to
believe that she might have been
damaging the floor she also reported
that once before dinner she'd set the
table but when the family returned to
eat the dishes had been put away the
middle son by the name of Bradley
claimed that the lights would flicker
and randomly turn off Carmen also
reported a terrifying event in which a
shower curtain almost suffocated her she
claims it mysteriously wrapped around
her face and she struggled to remove it
the family had reported that they would
often find old toe tags of the deceased
laying around oh that is too much number
one Oh No
okay other than just no other than the
tags being scary I don't buy anything
out of that it just sounds like typical
things what about the dishes lights
flicker you know what I think sometimes
someone can get so paranoid that they
just become forgetful or they start
believing yeah
scared me now you start believing things
they start yeah start getting they start
believing so much they start attracting
bad incidences that happened good point
or they yeah when they're so paranoid
they simply forgot because it's a ritual
a [ __ ] to notice you my dishes let me
see things that happened that's a good
point I don't like the tags thing that
was a little much for me there have been
people who have died from shower curtain
incidences where they didn't call it a
haunting yeah that's true it's called
negligence the word of the Lord well I
think the way they presented it made it
sound a lot scarier than it was yeah
well listen to what Thursday listen what
they're saying yeah and the images and
stuff with her like stroking her neck
like that's creepy
yeah so you're gonna take it as creepier
yeah listen to it like oh yeah yeah
you're right that is I feel uneasy now
you know just because of what you see
they did a good job in my video but it
is all about how the movie is based off
of this incident yeah the movie like
heightens it it makes it that's crazy
that's true let's watch the number one
number one originally released in 1970 a
medieval horror was also a remake
released in 2005 this movie follows a
beloved family they moved into a brand
new home located in Amityville New
York's are happy that the previous owner
had murdered his entire family right he
claims that the voices inside the house
persuaded him to do it after the Lutz
family move in supernatural occurrences
begin within the house one of the
children claims that she can speak to
the ghost of the daughter who was
murdered in the house the Paranormal
Activity continues and it's found out
that a cult leader also used to own the
house after this the man of the house by
the name of George Lutz becomes very
abusive against his wife his wife
believes he is possessed and quickly
flees from the house with the children
as he attempts to kill them the movie
was actually our drug sorry the movie
was actually based on the real-life Lutz
family they moved into a house in
Amityville Long Island in 1976 they only
lasted 28 days due to the chilling
events that took place the six bedroom
house had a swimming pool
boathouse it sounds like a really nice
place well it sure wasn't Dan juror was
10 years old while living there recently
revealed the nightmarish happenings he
claims he saw items fly across the room
and even saw substances spewing out of
the walls just over a year before they
man's disgust a man by the name of
Ronald Dafoe
shot and killed his parents and four
younger siblings it's believed that they
were killed at 3:15 a.m. the real George
looked reported that he would wake up
every night at 3:15 a.m. for no reason
although there was many reports of
paranormal happenings many believe that
their stories were fabricated this
includes a local lawyer who claimed that
the family made up the stories over many
bottles of wine people believe that they
simply left the house because George
couldn't afford it
due to his income thank you so much for
watching if you like horror I've done so
much Wow I believe him I believe it you
know why why is that story is so popular
yes I believe anything is popular window
oh my god
that's the way it works right I mean
Trump so popular no I knew you're right
president yeah I believe this family I
totally I you really do um I don't feel
like the whole family which is make up
some story you know if like the dad
liner was the only one who spoke about
it then I'd probably get it but if like
all these people are talking about it I
kind of believe it yeah yeah these are
crazy incidences
that's a fair point that's a good point
that's how I base my knowledge of who to
trust
are they all not so you know oh they all
not so we don't know so yeah they may
all be crazy yeah yeah I mean if the
dads crazy might have attracted a crazy
woman and then you know they have crazy
kids together and they believe all kinds
of crazy things make sense no I believe
it too though it's more fun to believe
it yeah we should go visit that house
sometime okay oh wow okay
right I'm not serious can you visit the
house yeah right
I reject subscribe today you get
accepted Lisa is on the channel of
Instagram called instagram.com / Lisa
and Malik and if you like Lisa and if
you like to look at her - then Instagram
is a place where you want to follow her
so go there thank you check her out on
Instagram okay boom that's how you
promote the guests are you from my I'm
not that
yeah no she's okay no girl I know
exactly what I'm doing
oh okay my bad